ce qui nous a manqué dans la sphère
skripal nous l'avons maintenant dans la
sphère navalni l'épreuve
un mois après l'empoisonnement présumé
l'équipe de l'opposant russe a diffusé
une vidéo où selon ses dires figure la
bouteille d'eau avec les traces du
fameux noeud vite choc
un scénario qui étrangement n'a pas
convaincu que le créateur du poison
lui-même ne pouvons pas parler ici du
novice choc parce que même des doses
faibles et non toxique provoque
inévitablement une contraction de la
pupille connu comme le mieux' mis dans
cet état il est extrêmement difficile
pour une personne de se déplacer donc
après même l'exposition la plus faible à
ce genre d'agents navalni n'aurais pas
pu me a river jusqu'à l'avion ni même
monter à son bord et nous avons vu des
photos de lui prises à bord de l'avion
dans un l'hôtel est alors qu'il était
transporté à l'hôpital et vers l'avion
allemand la partie allemande qui aurait
reçu sur la beauté avec ce poison
militaire extrêmement dangereux dans les
bagages d'une collaboratrice d'alexia
navale ne semble toujours en mesure d'en
communiquer les détails
le gouvernement fédéral a examiné la
vidéo publiée en ligne par l'équipe de
la vanille questions concernant cette
vidéo doivent être adressées aux
partisans nous avons déjà dit tout ce
que nous voulions dire à ce sujet dans
une communiqué de presse et déclarations
notamment ceux de la chancelière
fédérale
il n'y a rien a ajouté à ce sujet ce qui
n'empêche pas la résolution du parlement
européen elle d'être déjà prête
le renforcement des sanctions et l'arrêt
de la construction du gazoduc north
stream de tout simplement parce qu'il
est préférable de dépendre du gaz
américain que du gaz russe normal et les
plus chers je suis convaincu que si la
sphère navalni n'avait pas eu lieu
il aurait inventé autre chose est sûre à
ce stade tous visent à saper au maximum
les relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne
attachez les murs de recife est ce un
nombre de pays au sein de l'ue l'ont
compris mais il continue à appliquer le
principe de consensus
la prétendue solidarité et les pays qui
relève d'une minorité agressive
russophobe en abuse grossièrement à la
différence de la sphère skripal je vous
rappelle qu'on ignore toujours le sort
de l'ex espion et saphir à l'excès
navale et écrite déjà des récits
détaillés sur sa convalescence et
affirme vouloir revenir en russie
peut-être s'y sentirait est il plus en
sécurité